♪ ♪
>> Greg: SOME ARE CALLING IT A
FIRST EVER FOR CNN.
NO, NOT A RATINGS WIN.
IN FRONT OF AN AUDIENCE, YOU CAN
COUNT ON YOUR FINGERS AND TOES
ONE ANCHOR GAVE THIS MOMENT OF
SELF REFLECTION.
>> I THOUGHT HE COULD BE A
SERIOUS CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT.
IT WAS THAT STUPID ON MY PART?
WOULD YOU MAKE OF HOW HE WAS
COVERED BY NBC?
>> Greg: NOW THAT HE HAS BEEN
FOUND GUILTY OF EXTORTION ABOUT
TWO GO ON TRIAL, I THINK THE
ANSWER IS YES.
YOU WERE STUPID.
THAT’S PUTTING IT LIGHTLY.
THIS SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED A
WHILE AGO BEFORE ALL THE
MONTAGES KISSING HIS --
WHAT IF HE HADN’T BEEN FOUND
GUILTY?
IT WOULD HAVE LANDED RIGHT IN
CNN’S OPEN ARMS.
BUT I SHOULD STOP.
I’M BEING A --
YOU SHOULD NEVER MOCK SOMEONE
FOR DOING THE RIGHT THING, I SAY
GOOD JOB, BRIAN.
AND YOU TOO.
>> THE TOTAL COLLAPSE.
I FEEL KIND OF SNICKERED,
BECAUSE I TOOK HIM SERIOUSLY.
>> Greg: THAT MEANS THAT YOU
WERE UNFAIRLY TRICKED, THAT YOU
ARE THE VICTIM, BUT WHY WERE YOU
FEELFOOLED WHEN EVERYONE ELSE WA
WASN’T?
THE MEDIA’S EXCUSE WAS THAT
AVENATTI WAS A PART OF THE
STORY.
NO, THEY WERE LOOKING FOR A
SAVIOR.
AFTER ALL, WHERE IS THE
SPOTLIGHT NOW?
THEIR DESPERATION MADE THEM FOR
ANGELES.
HOORAY FOR SELF REFLECTION, BUT
REMEMBER THEY JUST SPENT YEARS.
THEY WILL BE BACK ON THAT HORSE
IN NO TIME LEAVING A TRAIL OF
MANEUVER KNOW NO MATTER WHERE TH
GO.
YOU AGREE WITH ME ON EVERYTHING
I JUST SAID, DON’T YOU?
[LAUGHTER]
WHY IS IT SO HARD FOR THE MEDIA
TO SELF REFLECT?
SPEAK OF THE MEDIA SHOULD.
WE ALL SHOULD.
THAT’S WHAT INSTITUTIONS DO.
LOOK, MICHAEL AVENATTI CAME TO
THE MEETING BACK IN 2019.
HE CAME FOR MY VOTE AND THE
VOTES OF OTHER DEMOCRATS.
MANY OF US LOOK HIM UP, LOOKED
HIM DOWN.
HE ALWAYS WORE NICE SUITS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: NOT THAT NIGHT.
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI, PUT IT THAT
WAY.
I HOPE HE GETS A FAIR TRIAL IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT $175 MILLION
WORTH OF FREE MEDIA.
DEFENDING STORMY DANIELS, GOING
OUT THERE WITH SOME OTHER
PERSON.
>> Greg: SPEAKING OF FREE
MEDIA, I WANT TO PLAY SOME FREE
MEDIA.
YOU GUYS ALL COMMENT ON IT.
THIS IS MORE OF THE OBSESSION
WITH AVENATTI.
>> I THINK THAT MUELLER IS NOT
GOING TO TAKE TRUMP DOWN.
I THINK THAT AVENATTI IS GOING
TO TAKE TRUMPED ON.
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> FOR PRESIDENT IN 2020?
>> HE IS DONALD TRUMP’S WORST
NIGHTMARE.
>> Greg: I DON’T KNOW WHO TO
CALL ON FOR THIS ONE WHERE THE
HOLY SPIRIT?
ANYBODY?
>> Greg:>> Emily: I’LL TAKE IT.
IF THERE IS A LOT OF HYPE ABOUT
SOMETHING, LIKE IF IT’S A GOOD
MOVIE OR NOVEL, I ALWAYS WANT TO
WAIT A MINUTE.
LET SOMEONE ELSE TEST THE TIRES
BEFORE I STEP IN.
>> Greg: EMILY, YOU’RE A
LAWYER.
I LOOK AT YOU DIFFERENTLY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Emily: WHAT?
I HAVE SO MANY TROUBLING ASPECTS
ABOUT THIS.
ONE OF THEM BEING THE TOTAL
COLLAPSE OF HIS LIFE.
THE TOTAL COLLAPSE DOESN’T
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
THAT’S LIKE WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT
A CELEBRITY OR A STAR, AND
YOU’RE LIKE NO, THAT WAS TEN
YEARS OF THEM SLEEPING IN THEIR
CAR AND GOING TO AUDITIONS
24 HOURS A DAY.
YOU DON’T GET TO A 36 COUNT
FEDERAL INDICTMENT WITHOUT YEARS
OF PREPARATION.
HE HASN’T PAID TAXES SINCE 2010.
SO THE NOTION, AND THAT DOESN’T
INCLUDE, BY THE WAY --
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Emily: HE GOT CAUGHT IS THE
BOTTOM LINE.
ALL OF THAT IS NOT ONLY
DISCOVERABLE, BUT OBVIOUS.
THE FACT IS THAT THIS IS LIKE
OH, WE HAD NO IDEA, ALL OF THIS
IS ABOUT THEM, NOT HIM.
>> WE NEED TO VET CABINET
MEMBERS.
WE NEED TO VET PEOPLE IN
GENERAL.
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE VETTING
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG.
OKAY?
>> Greg: WE KNOW BLOOMBERG.
WE KNEW TRUMPED.
WE DON’T KNOW THIS GUY.
DOES THIS GUY HAVE ANY EXCUSE
FOR SAYING THAT WE WERE
SNOOKERE?
>> Jesse: EVERYBODY AT THE
BAR KNOWS THAT SHE’S A --
THEY ARE ALL LAUGHING, BUT HE
THINKS HE’S IN LOVE.
NO ONE REALLY BELIEVES THERE’S A
CONNECTION THERE.
SHE TAKES HIS MONEY.
HE HAS A GOOD TIME, BUT HE
LEARNS NOTHING FROM IT AND HE
DOES IT AGAIN THE NEXT MONTH.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
MEDIA.
IF THE DOSSIER, IT’S COVINGTON.
THEY SAY GLOBAL WARMING IS GOING
TO KILL US IN TEN YEARS.
THESE PEOPLE GET TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF BY THE CIA, BY LEAKERS, BY
POLITICIANS, BY LOBBYISTS.
IF THEY HAD THE SAME AGENDA AS
YOU, THEY WOULD JUST BUY THE
MEDIA UP AND THEY ARE GONE THE
NEXT DAY.
>> WAITING IN THE WATER.
>> Dana: I MIGHT HAVE HELD
YOUR HAND ON THAT ONE.
THE MEDIA IS BEING USED AND THEY
KIND OF LIKE IT.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT.